- Oh my God.
(upbeat music)
Archie got hot!
He's got abs now!
(upbeat music)
- Let's see who's riding
the ginger stallion tonight.
- Six more reasons for you to take that
ginger bull by the horns tonight.
- Real.
About my life and what I
should be trying to do with it.
- I have this fantasy
of us as a power couple.
Or maybe even just a couple.
- Betty
- Is that so impossible to imagine?
♪ We ain't got no guilt ♪
♪ Won't hesitate ♪
♪ So back off or we'll
put you in your place ♪
♪ Haven't you heard ♪
♪ We're on top of the world ♪
- Veronica Lodge.
- Archie. Andrews.
This is Betty Cooper.
- To be continued.
♪ We're on top of the world ♪
♪ Oh yeah ♪
♪ Haven't you heard ♪
- [Male] Oh, no way!
- [Cheryl] The new girl.
- Ask me a question, Archie.
Ask me anything you want.
We shouldn't do this.
- We definitely shouldn't do this.
♪ Lay you on the floor ♪
♪ Heavy at the force ♪
♪ Between us ♪
- Okay, good as new.
But try to take better care of it.
That hand is going to be
worth millions one day.
♪ Heavy at the force ♪
♪ Between us ♪
(laughter)
- I'm messed up, Veronica.
- We all are, Archie.
And, honestly, you less than most.
♪ Halted in flight ♪
♪ Bleeding ♪
♪ I was only falling in love ♪
Archie and I wanted to tell you--
- We've kissed a couple times.
- It's okay with me.
I appreciate you being honest with me.
I'm with Jughead now.
If you guys want to be
together, I'm happy for you.
- Thanks, B.
- Thanks Betty.
♪ I was only falling in love ♪
(soft music)
- Maybe it's not right, but it's real.
Which is why we,
you can't go to Weatherby.
If you do that, we will
never see each other again.
Archie, I'm putting myself in your hands.
- I don't want to end our lessons, but--
- That's what you think we should do.
- Don't you?
- Still have that bow?
It's a goodbye gift.
- Well, well, well.
There they are.
What did I tell you?
- Can someone tell me
what's going on here?
- Of course.
Archie, would you like to share with us
what you and Mrs. Robinson have been doing
during your music lesson?
And please, don't leave out
any of the lurid details,
because Betty here keeps
a very meticulous diary,
and I'm more than happy
to fill in the details.
♪ Top of the world, ♪
♪ but we want more ♪
♪ Oh oh oh ♪
♪ Don't have enough, so
we'll take what's yours ♪
♪ Oh oh oh ♪
♪ Smile ♪
♪ Let the games begin ♪
♪ Oh oh oh ♪
♪ Never break a sweat ♪
- So perfect when you play.
- We wrote a good song, Archie.
- I can't wait to sing
it with you in public.
But just not tonight.
Val, you should play with the Pussycats.
I don't want to be the guy
that broke up the Beatles.
- Archie!
♪ Haven't you heard ♪
♪ Oh oh oh ♪
♪ We're on top of the world ♪
♪ Haven't you heard ♪
♪ Oh yeah ♪
I'm done with you.
Ever since we started
dating, you've ignored me.
You've ditched me.
- Val, please.
Let me make it up to you.
- Sorry, Archie, but unlike you,
I won't be bought.
♪ You've gotta work for it ♪
♪ Haven't you heard ♪
- Looking extremely DILF-y today
Is Archie home?
- Cheryl.
Yes.
Come on in.
- Hey, Cheryl.
- As a maj thank you for coming
to the Maple Banquet with me tomorrow,
I wanted to give you this.
An '84 Les Paul.
You're welcome.
See you tomorrow.
Oh, Archie.
Sometimes I think you may be the only
decent person left in Riverdale.
The only person who doesn't
want something from me,
or who doesn't want me to
apologize for who I am,
what I want.
(upbeat music)
- What are you doing?
- My lipstick's Maple Red, by the way.
In case you're wondering
why it tastes so sweet.
(upbeat music)